so uh Kiera you wrote a column over at
louder with Crowder calm which means
that fun dip did not read it hey why are
you saying that I've read things on
there before oh come on
I read at least one thing on there
before yeah if I tell them just you
should read this one you'll like this
one
I promise what's it about it's about
Starbucks but it's funny and I think
it's probably the best thing you'll ever
read in your whole life I don't want to
oversell it but I don't - amazing piece
of work I'll agree it's pretty
incredible got a lot of people out a lot
of people read it and I think Kiera
listen I know you I know you hate this
right being pigeon-holed but I think it
struck a lot of think it struck a chord
with a lot of people because you're a
black conservative and right away people
are are their ears perk up and go wait
hold on a second this is an opinion from
someone you know who we can't accuse it
being a racist and so conservatives want
to hear what you have to say and
liberals have to listen because they
can't just use the go-to straw man
argument of racism right so tell us from
your point of view the Starbucks what it
is this race together and why you were
so worked up by that tells me about well
the race together if you haven't heard
by now you've been living in a hole but
it's Starbucks new initiative proposed
by their CEO Howard Schultz the idea is
to get people talking about race by
putting hashtag race together on the
cups of customers in order to initiate a
conversation with customers about raisin
and advance race relations in the United
States now I don't want to belittle the
idea that it's constructive to talk
about race relations we've been talking
about a national conversation about race
for as long as I can remember we've
never been able to have that
conversation honestly in my opinion and
I don't think we ever will but I know
one thing I don't want to have that
conversation at 5:30 in the morning with
my barista before I have even had my
first sip of caffeine that's like a
giant No what's
what's the female term for Uncle Tom is
it aunt Tomlin and Jemima Aunt Jemima
who I'm here how I want I want waffles
man Tom I'm handsome aunt Tom this going
on here
you know you say okay here's what here's
my ignorant white guy view right um I
was watching MSNBC actually clip you
showed me in this lady saying at least
this should start the race dialogue
being raised in a post-racial America uh
where there were no riots there was no
segregation there was no established
enforced racism you get racist jackasses
everywhere um I feel like there's been
nothing but a dialogue these last like
let's start a dialogue I'm going where
have I been
everything's been about race it's
everything I totally agree I feel the
exact same way and I get fatigued um to
the point where I am fatigued about
talking about this because like I say
we're never going to have beyond this
conversation the national conversation
in quotes about race that we keep having
is white people bad everybody else good
now I'm not here to defend white people
or to say that white people never do
anything wrong and people need to you
know get over that but what I am saying
is that this is a nuanced debate and if
black people want to have this
conversation we need to be willing to
have some uncomfortable conversations
and make some uncomfortable admissions
as well and I have yet to see anybody
who's willing to do that I mean Bill
Cosby God rest his soul
I noticed that dad said depends on how
much of his own coffee he's been
drinking he may be in a stupor wake up
nine months from now yeah but uh you
know he had the nerve and Bill Cosby is
by no means the conservative he is not a
conservative
he hates conservatives he is not by any
stretch of the imagination but he had
the nerve to come out and say look like
people we have some responsibilities
here we need to stop this horrific out
of wedlock birth rate that we have
because the family is the bedrock of any
successful society and when you break
down the family you break down that
society and that's what we're seeing in
black America we've got to stop these
terrible
rates we have to look we've to stop
these horrible dropout rates we have to
look inside our community no one is
coming in and pulling our boys out of
school yet we have a 50% dropout rate
nationwide among young black males
that's you just 50% half of young black
males don't finish school I have yet to
see one Republican come into the hood
and pull a young black man out of school
and say son you're you're just not going
to finish so there's some responsibility
that we have for ourselves and white
people also have a responsibility sure
I'm not for this idea that we should
talk about race at all or that it
doesn't matter I don't believe that
either but I do think that there's got
to be some uncomfortable conversations
that have to be had if we're going to
really have a national conversation
about race but we sure as heck are not
going to have them at Starbucks this is
true yeah I don't want to leave the 19
year old dropout hipster barista in
charge of race relations I do not I
don't think that's the right place to go
uh you know it's it's funny you mention
that there's there's a real correlation
actually between French Canadians and
and black Americans in the sense that
you might not know this Steven I'm not
sure if you know but I'm Canadian Tire I
do know that we talked about this
yesterday in our pronunciation of dolars
all right but french-canadian that's
almost a 50% dropout rate uh yeah they
don't get married the abortion rate is
one of the highest in the industrialized
world very similar you know to black
Americans who have about the same chance
of being born as I do of being aborted
in America right now so you see a lot of
those correlations in the French
Canadian community that you would see
with the with the black American
community which which tells me again
having been a witness to that it's not a
race issue in that sense those numbers
aren't a racist you're not born black
and decide to not be a father it's a
cultural issue and you feel like while
we're talking about co-opting people
saying you know you're co-opting
blackness you know if you're white like
mm well isn't it isn't the whole hip-hop
culture a co-opting of blackness to
begin with this idea of of uh be et and
gang-related
imagery and symbolism and culture even
if a black person is doing that how is
that not co-op co-opting blackness
before white people do it well I
disagree with you I don't I wouldn't say
it's a co-opting but I would say it's an
expression of Jackman's but I am not
really excited about this idea so I
think some people do co-opt the culture
but it happens all the time and I know
Katy Perry got a little bit of trouble
by co-opting Asian culture in an MTV
Awards performance that she gave
recently but I think there's a
difference between co-opting and
honoring and it's all in how you
approach it some people really respect
the black culture Beastie Boys great
group you know I guess well let me
clarify my point my point is that that's
not emblematic of all black culture I
mean people say people act as when they
say well black culture you know if you
well no no it's not it's not black
culture for example black culture fund
it wants to say something but hold on
one second fund it the Blues are black
culture rock and roll as black culture
bluegrass but these things came to us
from the black community I don't know
why now we act like the current trend is
emblematic of all black culture in the
country because I mean you look at what
blues did for America I mean that's all
we gonna say fund up your music guy yeah
I was just thinking about blues and
Motown music Motown's phrasing of how
they described their music wasn't this
is for black America it was this is for
young the music of young America and
everyone black white you name it was
putting on The Supremes The Four Tops
the temptations the whole nation was
embracing that music that came out of
Detroit and I'd hate to think that every
time I strap on my Fender bass and try
to play Bernadette and nowhere near what
Jamerson did that I'm co-opting because
that's the greatest bass line of all
time I don't want to say I'm co-opting I
I love it I wanna get your point
Kyra I think you should be right I do I
think I don't think Katy Perry even Gwen
Stefani she went through a phase in her
career where she was all under these
Japanese Harajuku Girls I don't think
that
you should be accused of co-opting
culture that you admire and you and you
want to participate in the expression of
that culture and I think I think
fundings up a great point about wanting
to you know participate that in that and
being a fan I mean there's no it's not
offensive and it shouldn't be offensive
for someone to say I love the way you
express yourself this brings me joy and
I would love to see the black the black
American community get back to the point
where we are significant contributors
positive contributors to American
culture I mean we have literally built
this country on our backs we have been a
part of the history of this culture in
this continent you know for hundreds of
years and yet these days we don't
conduct ourselves with that level of
pride we have so many issues in our
community it just I I want to get back
to the place where where we are
considered great contributors to to
culture right and you know I guess it's
good can you stay for another segment
here kurrekurre do you have to go your
spin class no spin class I got that okay
yeah I was a cure actually she's up very
early she's on the west coast for us and
that we will be back with Kiera Davis
ladder with Crowder stay tuned
find her you can find her what are you
pointing at me fun dip because I pointed
at you but I had my hand on the music
and forgot to turn on your mic oh gosh
and we had that beautiful intro now this
is why we can't have nice things
funded our guests our I've only had two
cups of coffee so I'm kind of slow today
all right miss Kyra Davis you can find
her at Ft our radio.com and her recent
column a lot with Crider comm thank you
for being back with us Kyra and I
apologize on behalf of fun dip so before
we left we're talking about the
Starbucks deal and you mentioned that
you think there needs to be an honesty
and the race conversation if we're going
to have it if you have to pinpoint where
is that like what what is it that needs
to be discussed most that is not being
injected into the issue right now well I
think on the part of and I can only
speak up speak on this from the point of
view of a black person and white America
sure I know there's other races but
that's the only part I can speak on but
I think as a black community we need to
be willing to address the fact that
sometimes we play a part in the fear
that people have of us we have high
crime rates in our community we have
high murder rates in our community we
have high abortion rates high dropout
rates so there's a lot of things that we
are doing that we are solely responsible
for you cannot be blamed on other people
we need to recognize make it more
difficult for us to be successful in
this country you know we're kind of our
own worst enemy I think on the part of
white people a lot of white people need
to recognize that a we don't need you to
roll over on the race to B I think
that's just as offensive as as not
wanting to discuss it at all I can't
I hate it when I hear a white person say
well you know I'm not qualified to speak
on the subject you know i'll just defer
well no that's the chicken way out
that's the chicken beyond i think white
people need to be honest right and part
of that is on us to not make if we're
going to have an honest debate and an
honest discussion and if a white person
says well you know i do have these
questions i do have these
problems we should really kill them
right away and judge them right away
you're racist you're horrible you know
we should be willing at least be honest
don't you do that every now and then
when you just really want the person to
shut up
you use it every now and that you must
allocate lies like a lot of sites incur
beauty Susy other when she gives a Larry
David a script she owes did you get the
new script I said because yeah I did
they weren't did you tell him I was
black why would I Larry you need to know
when to use the race card all level and
liberal and crap
they gotta love that black writer go
give me a script they don't buy my
script you gotta know where to use it
nothing I feel like it's true you know
and it's just like I'm a woman and
there's some of my womanly wiles that
I'll use to get ahead sometimes I think
I'll tell you where my favorite place to
use it that was it's with other liberals
it's with liberals yeah when so goes
because I can't stand being called
racist so if I get into like a situation
where liberals are like getting all high
and mighty I'll be like well you know I
guess what do I know I'm just a little
old black girl and you're the house you
know oh my gosh no I'm not racist at all
my best friend is a platform when I was
a kid I went to school with with that
with two black people and one of them
was my best friend and I defended her
against insults I'm not a racist
then what'd you do to make it feel
really bad just act like really
submissive like yes sir no sir
I'll make you some pancakes er no no no
no could you turn on a night light mr.
jingles gets a little scared dog
sometimes that's what yeah I wasn't
I can't you well it's not it's not fair
but it's not fair but it works it just
doesn't work throwing out the Irish were
slaves to card because I've tried that
Oh No especially not with a black person
yeah it doesn't work at all I'm like
darn it I read that whole book on Irish
being slaves and I got nothing right
people let me let me just say this when
you're arguing with anybody about race
be them be they conservative or liberal
or we don't want to hear about how black
people participated in the slave trade -
and there's a lot of slavery going on in
Africa right now like everybody knows
that but it's
as you bring that up it's just a
non-starter don't it doesn't add to the
conversation I know you have valid
points and I recognize that it's a valid
point but you sort of stop the
intellectual trajectory of the
conversation I think when you go there
it's not it doesn't help I think the
purpose that it does serve is not saying
well their slavery somewhere else but I
would say you know listen the United
States is not unique in that it engaged
in slavery but it is singularly unique
in that it had a revolution to end
slavery sure a great point right well
for example you know both of us being
you know Canadian I find it funny had
someone one time uh actually Colin I
think to this show and fund it was he
and he said you know my my grandfather
was a black I say you know my
grandfather fled slavery to Canada and I
said what do you know what they would
have said in Canada great more slaves
where did this start where they thought
there was no slavery in Canada I mean I
know I I did a video we're back in 2012
is I have a YouTube channel by the way
you can look me up on YouTube Keira
Davis k IRA Davis um where I do a lot of
political commentary just me and my
webcam kind of like you see now and but
it was during the 2012 campaign and I
think to array from MSNBC had accused
Mitt Romney of being a racist so I made
this video about you know well when you
call someone a racist use you lay all
this history at their feet you don't
really know what racism is and I talked
about my experience which we were
talking about during the break Stephen
in eastern Canada growing up is the only
black person on this little island and
pretty much got called the n-word every
day and got beat up every school day I
related a story about being in a diner
with friends one time and this drunk guy
like an adult coming in and yelling at
me about picking cotton and going back
to where I came from going back to
Africa and I was like 12 years old you
know and so I told that story and what a
lot of people reacted to was that it
happened in Canada they couldn't they
were like what there's but Kara is this
Oasis it's like this utopia communions
aren't racist Canadians aren't mean
I have been all over this continent I
have lived a few decades not going to
say Benny how many right now but I have
a lot of life experience and I can tell
you this
a holes are everywhere no they
absolutely are and um and then you take
into account that Canada most places
just doesn't have the same kind of color
palette that we have in the United
States like I said you're the only black
person it's very homogenous uh where I
was raised in Montreal you know we had a
very large percentage of my school was
was Arabic and then quite a few Asians
in uh honestly I could count on one hand
the amount of black kids in the entire
school they're sure to be more toward my
senior year because of the French
language laws again big government
discriminatory laws you know how that
works with the the the language police
in Quebec encouraged a lot of Haitian
immigration right they speak French and
French Canadians of the most racist
people on the planet then they were
trying to figure out how now we have all
these people these Asian dammit we don't
want them taking our our business over
so we're gonna give them a poll tax or
something like that
Carlos Akana they were furious about it
so and it's okay you have a
french-canadian past just like Kyra
Davis that's her right French Lee French
Canadians are the ghetto French of the
world it's funny just like the French
French it's just they're more ghetto
yes exactly well they're don't tell that
to Celine Dion though what was that fun
Depp don't tell that to Celine Dion and
her expensive dresses I know I tell you
what though when you want a song sung
properly you get so in to do it only in
French I don't like when she sings in
English call yeah I know but we're
saying compared to Marat when people say
like the best singers of all time Mariah
Carey Whitney I'm like now none of them
are close to Celine as far as hitting
notes you can cover up a lot with vocal
gymnastics and that's all I carry does
words you know she goes on this run I
was like have you ever actually just
held a note Mariah
I've never heard Celine is a is a pro
and I know we're supposed to hate her
because we got overloaded with Celine
during the Titanic years but um and
she's I don't own any music by her but
she's definitely a pro yeah there you go
you don't know you don't mess with
Celine fund if she's a national
treasure the only stuff I owned by her
she's singing in French there you go oh
those who sleepy on and Michael J Fox
lay off
oh yeah quiz your eighty raha and John
Candy John Candy is like a God in camera
I don't know I met him he was a nicest
man I ever met
yep of all the celebrities have ever met
and I met a lot of them because I worked
as a stagehand at the Just for Laughs my
mom was a costume designer before I ever
performed there John Candy was the
kindest person I had ever met and he
died about two months after I met him oh
yeah so I was one the last people
anyways we have to let you go
Keira so where can people find you most
effectively people can buy me online you
buy me on YouTube k IRA datasets Keira
Davis check out my radio show which airs
Tuesday nights on FTR radio.com and you
can also look me up at IJ review.com as
well thanks for having me on Steven I
really had a good time today oh we're so
glad to have you on hopefully we'll see
more of your work at ladder with Crowder
comm because the audience loved it and
we will be back after this commercial
break from our sponsors hey if you
enjoyed this video subscribe by clicking
my face or click this video next to me
it's playing right now in a box how do
we do that that's the magic of the
Internet is it still playing still
playing I don't want to look at it still
playing isn't it